la phrase du sommet franco-britannique
entente cordiale et constat de désaccord
sur les problèmes européens en espagne
enterrement du général assassiné hier
par l'été à militaire basse tension dans
l'armée
jacques tati est mort le cinéaste
français avait 75 ans les préparatifs de
la route du rhum à saint-malo 54 marin
qui s'apprêtent à traverser l'atlantique
en solitaire
madame monsieur bonsoir il nous a fait
rire sourire et rêver il a réalisé que
trois ou quatre films à succès et
pourtant son nom appartient depuis
longtemps déjà à la grande tradition du
cinéma français un cinéma où personnages
solitaires
insatisfait il occupait une place bien à
part jacques tati vient de mourir à
l'âge de 75 ans monsieur hulot mon oncle
et tous ses personnages lui survivent
france roche déjà le faire vivre pour
nous j'ai voulu un sourire
s'autoriser gorille et je crois est un
des rares
cinéaste
accepter que les gens parlent pendant la
projection
qui tu es libre le monde entier c'était
monsieur un personnage à mi chemin entre
le dessin et la réalité
farfelu et apparemment inoffensifs mais
sa seule présence était polémique
il se voulait l'homme libre au milieu
des cités forteresse le poète au milieu
des stéréotypes il connu trois carrières
celle d'abord de clown acrobatique
surgissant sur les scènes de music hall
en patins à roulettes son premier numéro
en 33 est une parodie de tous les sports
boxe équitation football tennis son
corps était aussi agile que son
imagination de gagman il y a toujours
des enfin je veux dire dans les films à
prétention comique il y a toujours un
effort physique de toute façon plus le
volant d'une voiture ou peu
et d'aller sur une bicyclette voulait
d'abord nous occuper la place vous devez
d'abord bien monter à cheval à l'église
il est certain que dans tout ce qui est
visuel
bon cinéma l'apport physique et le sport
c'est vrai dans sa seconde carrière fut
celle de réalisateur il commença par le
court métrage en financer nous mêmes
c'est fini un si court métrage tourné en
couleurs plusieurs ag dimension d'un
film d'une heure trente est tirée envoie
réjouis que l'argent est refusé par
toutes les cintres une représentation
surprise improvisé dans l'intitulé y est
infligée le flou enfants il est couronné
à jeanine et remporte le grand prix du
championnat français je revends louche
les vacances de monsieur hulot puis mon
oncle valtat tati un succès
international la france écriteau espion
chacune une sorte d'anarchiste
misanthrope ronchonneurs et fleur bleue
mais vient l'automne de sa carrière
tati dont les films sont moins rentables
voit les producteurs devenir plus rares
et puis les clowns font moins rire quand
il saute moins vite et moins haut
l'âge est venu sa santé s'altère il
préside des festivals on lui rendait
hommage ainsi en mairie à cannes mais il
ne tourne plus cependant son nom restera
sur l'écran sophie tatischeff sa fille a
pris la relève
ces courts-métrages déjà montré des plis
on sent là pu mentir le premier ministre
et le ministre de la culture salue l'un
et l'autre la mémoire de jacques tati le
cinéma français lui dois beaucoup
déclare monsieur mauroy la série noire
continue aujourd'hui pour le cinéma
français ifsi en pis 61 ans est mort ce
matin d'une crise cardiaque ifsi en pis
médecin de formation cinéaste de
vocations avait signé entre autres les
héros sont fatigués typhon sur nagasaki
ce sont ces deux plus grands succès il
est en train de monter un film sur la
marine et devaient commencer un téléfilm
c'est en en grande pompe et en silence
que l'armée espagnole a c'est vrai
aujourd'hui les funérailles de la
dernière victime du séparatisme basque
l'assassinât du général
lago romane le commandant de la
prestigieuse division brunette a été
revendiquée la nuit dernière par les
terres militaire qui signe ainsi sa
déclaration de guerre au nouveau pouvoir
socialiste
nous ne combattons pas le franquisme
mais l'espagne avait déclaré il ya plus
de dix ans au procès de burgos
l'un des chefs de l'été à cette phrase
l'attentât d'hier vient de la mettre à
jour de l'actualité politique et c'est
bien ce qui inquiète à la fois même si
leurs raisons ne sont pas toujours les
mêmes
le pouvoir militaire et le pouvoir civil
en espagne philippe gassot la hiérarchie
militaire espagnol au grand complet a
assisté aux funérailles du général
victor lago romane l'un de ses généraux
sera peut-être demain
la prochaine cible de l'êta militaire
c'est la grande crainte des espagnols
l'organisation basque pourrait profiter
du vide politique actuel pour pousser
l'armée dont les velléités putschistes
ne sont plus à des les faits a tenté un
nouveau coup d'état
le nouveau gouvernement socialiste qui
n'entrera en fonction que le 2 décembre
est bien décidé à combattre le
terrorisme par tous les moyens
l'été à militaire a devant elle
pratiquement un mois pour essayer de
faire sortir leurs mets de ses casernes
si tel est son but les sentiments avoué
des responsables militaires
la douleur et la rage à tel point que
l'aumônier des armées a mis en garde les
soldats contre toute tentation
antidémocratique
le successeur du général assassiné a
déjà réclamé des mesures plus efficaces
afin d'en finir avec la terreur selon un
quotidien centriste de madrid 12 soldats
en colère ont été mis aux arrêts
l'inquiétude est grande aussi dans les
rangs socialiste felipe gonzalez futur
chef du gouvernement pense que
l'assassinât met en péril la démocratie
et la paix pour lui les auteurs de
l'attentât sont les assassins de
l'espérance la minorité extrémiste
basque est capable de récidiver
préférant sans doute lutter contre un
goût
militaire issu d'un coup d'état plutôt
que d'affronter un gouvernement élu
démocratiquement
candia lité et franchise ces deux mots
qui résument le sommet franco
britannique qui vient de se terminer à
paris signifie aussi au delà du rituel
diplomatique que madame thatcher et le
président mitterrand a sorti des membres
de leur gouvernement
on était d'accord sur tout sauf sur les
progrès les problèmes qui touchent
directement aux intérêts économiques des
deux pays
le problème le plus épineux demeure
celui de la contribution britannique au
budget de la communauté
si pour l'année 82 une compensation a
été accordées à la grande bretagne la
france n'entend pas qu'il en soit de
même en 83 et le président mitterrand
dans une conférence de presse commune
avec le premier ministre britannique l'a
bien précisé
vous le savez on peut isoler un problème
particulier qui chez difficulté qui
n'est pas résolu qui continuera d'être
discuté entre nous elle celui de la
contribution
cela a déjà fait l'objet de plusieurs
sommets de la communauté on y est arrivé
vaille que vaille
depuis 1981 différents accords
on ne s'est pas mis d'accord sur les
principes nous continuons d'en discuter
pour être tout à fait précis
le débat porte non pas sur le principe
d'une contribution
elle porte sur son volume et sur sa
durée et même sur certains plans à
l'idée qu'on s'en fait ce septième
sommet franco britannique n'aura donc
pas apporté de véritables surprises
l'atmosphère a été une nouvelle fois
cordiale entre françois mitterrand et
margaret thatcher une cordialité
d'ailleurs encore renforcée par la
décision française hier soir à l'onu de
s'abstenir de voter sont la sphère des
malouines les deux dirigeants sont par
ailleurs tombés d'accord sur l'analyse
des grands problèmes internationaux du
moment c'est à dire la sphère du gazoduc
les rapports est ouest ou encore la
sécurité européenne
reste que le dossier le plus important à
savoir l'europe ce dossier n'a pas été
réglé on ne s'attendait sans doute pas à
un miracle mais il apparaît bien ce soir
que les positions françaises et
britanniques
ces positions sont en ce domaine plus
divergentes que jamais notamment pour ce
qui concerne la contribution britannique
au budget européen
vous venez de l'entendre mais cela pose
à nouveau la question de la présence
britannique dans le marché commun car
l'époque où l'allemagne fédérale et la
france était prête à payer pour la
grande bretagne
cette époque semble maintenant révolue
ces deux pays traverse aujourd'hui une
crise grave et sont beaucoup moins
accessible aux exigences de la grande
bretagne
ce sera l'un des points forts du sommet
européen du copenhague le mois prochain
un sommet qui promet d'être difficile
une victoire en tout cas pour la france
à l'issue de ce sommet une victoire dans
la guerre des volailles les autorités
britanniques accepte en effet les
étiquettes française dont le format
jusqu'ici leur servait de prétexte pour
en interdire l'importation au grand dam
de madame cresson le cinpec annuler la
réunion des partenaires sociaux sur
l'assurance-chômage réunion qui était
prévue pour lundi prochain le patronat
manifeste ainsi sa grogne après les
déclarations d'hier du premier ministre
sur la politique économique et sociale
du gouvernement
la décision du sintef est évidemment
critiqué par tous les syndicats
en effet le patronat a mal accueilli les
mesures annoncées hier par monsieur
mauroy même si certaines vont dans le
sens d'un allègement des charges des
entreprises des entreprises qui
traversent souvent une passe difficile
le problème clé l'endettement comme le
prouve en quête d'eau roselyne koskas
c'est une toute petite pme tout à fait
ordinaire une petite entreprise de 20
personnes à peine qui fabrique des
presses hydrauliques depuis cinq ans ici
armés qu'à la crise a frappé plus fort
qu'ailleurs les gros clients ceux de
l'électronique de l'électroménager ou de
la mécanique ont diminué leurs commandes
de machines ou les ateliers se vide et
pour tenir
jean royer le pdg d'arm eca doit bien
sûr faire appel aux banques
eh bien nous sommes endettés parce que
nous avons travaillé avec des grosses
sociétés qui n'ont absolument pas retenu
leurs conditions de règlement
deuxièmement nous sommes en été
également parce que nous avons cru a
ordonné à des commandes importantes de
la part de l'automobile et nous avons
conservé trop longtemps du personnel
donc vous avez dû faire appel aux
banques
alors nous avons fait appel aux ventes
nous avons fait appel au privé aussi je
me suis endetté personnellement et vous
trouvez que vous payez trop bon oui oui
je paye trop moitié parce que monde est
content que l'année dernière soit mort
s'il doit faire de 450 millions de
centimes j'ai payé 50 millions
uniquement frais financiers c'est
absolument imbuvable l'étau se referme
donc sur jean royer et pourtant il ne
désespère pas c'est vrai dit il on ne
prête qu'aux riches
mais son entreprise ne doit pas mourir
dans l'état actuel des choses elle va
avoir des difficultés mais je pense que
les gens pourront le nom gouvernants
vont réagir suffisamment tôt pour nous
permettre justement cette continuation
et pas fermer complètement
on n'avait pas envie de mettre à
trie-sur-baïse faut absolument pas et
pourquoi pas pour une raison simple
c'est que c'est moi qui ai créé cette
entreprise y avait un temps et nous
avons très bien techniques que nous
sommes pratiquement les seuls en france
à faire ce que nous faisons
il n'y a pas de raison si les gens
achètent français de que l'on ne s'en
sortent pas si les commandes repartent
et surtout si ces charges financières
diminuent pour une fois jean royer
pourra sans difficulté financer ses
investissements
oui certaines des mesures annoncées hier
par monsieur mauroy devrait sur ce
plan-là améliorer le sort des
entreprises des blocages des honoraires
médicaux après l'accord intervenu hier
entre les caisses de sécurité sociale et
les organisations professionnelles de
praticiens
le tarif de la consultation passerait de
55 à 60 francs pour le généraliste et
pour le spécialiste de 80 à 87 francs
ces nouveaux tarifs prendrait effet le
15 novembre à l'assemblée nationale les
députés ont poursuivi aujourd'hui leurs
examens du premier budget de la nation
celui de l'éducation nationale
un budget qui comme d autres portent la
marque de la rigueur en 83 8000 postes
nouveaux seront créés contre quatorze
mille pour l'année en cours et ces
restrictions nourrissent bien sûr les
critiques souvent acerbes des
enseignants et des parents
sans parler de celles de l'opposition en
raison du chômage des jeunes l'effort
dans le budget 83 porte surtout sur
l'enseignement professionnel lorraine
pusa les lycées d'enseignement
professionnel élèves qui forment des
ouvriers qualifiés ont la moitié des
nouveaux moyens en hommes et matériel 13
100 nouveaux postes investissements
locaux et machines plus 60%
l'élève qui ont dû refuser de nombreux
élèves cette année faute de places
pourront en accueillir 18 mille de plus
les bourses accordées à ces jeunes
souvent défavorisées sont aussi
sensiblement relevé
on s'était préoccupé beaucoup
tous des lycées d'enseignement
professionnel on connaît très
certainement pas la situation qu'on a
aujourd'hui
car si on prenait en charge pendant leur
scolarité les jeunes qui cherchent à
apprendre un métier
on n'aurait pas besoin aujourd'hui de
solution de rattrapage tels que les
formules 16 18 ans ou apprentissage est
fort aussi mais plus infimes pour les
lycées techniques qui forment eux des
techniciens 4000 élèves de plus et fort
qu'ils ne suffira pas doubler les
sections de techniciens supérieurs dont
l'économie a besoin surtout dans les
secteurs de pointe
les investissements dans ces lycées sont
les plus coûteux certes mais les
enseignants craignent de prendre du
retard sur l'industrie ce qui n'est pas
adapté actuellement c'est le problème en
fait la liaison école industrie car nous
mêmes lorsqu'il rencontre en stage dans
l'industrie constate qu'il y avait
parfois une assez grande différence
entre l'enseignement qu'on leur donne et
le travail qui se fait dans l'industrie
tourcoing
les études qui se font dans l'industrie
pour les collèges ont 100 nouveaux
professeurs mais d'une manière générale
dans le secondaire on fait des économies
économies sur les heures supplémentaires
économies d'énergie les crédits de
fonctionnement des établissements sont
absorbés par le coût du chauffage et il
est difficile d'acquérir des moyens
pédagogiques modernes
quant à l'enseignement privé dossier
délicat à la veille des négociations sur
son avenir
sa dotation progresse moins que pour
l'enseignement public les années
précédentes c'est l inverse
cette augmentation moins rapide est dû à
deux phénomènes le premier set phénomène
quasiment mécanique ou automatique
c'est le fait que les lois existantes et
notamment la loi de gamer commence à
voir leurs effets qui a des limites
dans le temps s'estomper et le deuxième
c'est la volonté politique du ministre
de ne pas privilégier l'enseignement
privé par rapport au service public de
l'éducation nationale comme nous
estimons que les prédécesseurs le
faisait à l'école élémentaire pas de
nouveaux instituteurs le nombre d'élèves
est nettement en baisse les moyens
récupérer permettront d'accueillir 70
mille enfants de plus en maternelle ou
les listes d'attentes se sont allongées
la préparation des élections municipales
les socialistes parisiens ont élu hier
soir leur chef de file pour les listes
parisienne une liste sans surprise où
l'on relève les noms de deux ministres
jacques lang edwige avice ainsi que ceux
de lionel jospin et paul quilès c'est
mercredi prochain que lionel jospin et
georges marchais discuterons ensemble de
l'épineux problème des têtes de liste
d'union de la majorité à paris et
ailleurs
la cote du chef de l'état en hausse
celle de son premier ministre en baisse
après le sondage publié par paris match
le baromètre du figaro magazine illustre
la même tendance
53% des personnes interrogées contre 43
font confiance monsieur mitterrand deux
points de plus que le mois dernier
en revanche monsieur mauroy baisse de 2
fois au concours de popularité michel
rocard reste en tête des personnalités
de la majorité
mais c'est pierre bérégovoy qui grimpe
le plus du côté de l'opposition madame
simone veil progresse encore devant
jacques chirac et valéry giscard
d'estaing à l'étranger
notons d'abord une déclaration
importante du roi hussein de jordanie
qui hier à londres
appelez-le olp à reconnaître le droit
d'israël à exister même si la jordanie
de son côté continue de ne pas
reconnaître l'état hébreu
notons aussi en afrique un nouveau
départ volontaire du pouvoir après le
sénégalais senghor le président du
cameroun monsieur ahidjo 58 ans qui
depuis plus de 20 ans et est l'artisan
est le symbole de l'unification du
cameroun monsieur ahidjo démissionne
pour raisons de santé semble-t-il
il sera remplacé par l'actuel premier
ministre le pape jean paul 2 poursuite
en espagne son long périple le saint
père était aujourd'hui en andalousie qui
pour lui a déployé ses splendeurs
françois corner castagnettes mantis et
dentelle c'est l'accueil de l'andalousie
à jean paul ii 6e jour de la visite du
souverain pontife en espagne ces vignes
sur l'esplanade de la feria un million
de fidèles acclament le pas venu ici
procéder à la béatification d'une
religieuse sévillanes morte en 1932
soeur angela de la cruz fondatrice de la
congrégation de la croix qui depuis son
origine se consacrent déshérités c'est
la deuxième fois dans l'histoire de
l'église et leur première fois en europe
qu'une béatification est célébrée hors
de rome depuis la création de la
congrégation des rites en 1588 les 190 1
et les 187 bienheureux ont été proclamés
dans la basilique saint-pierre en
surimpression sur la foule va apparaître
la statue de la vierge des rois patronne
de céline la visite du souverain pontife
en espagne s'achèvera mardi prochain
l'afer est hors du commun et d'un pas
fini de soulever les commentaires et
même les passions à la grande motte dans
l'hérault une jeune femme est enceinte
elle est enceinte de son beau frère
car sa soeur sa soeur jumelle qui ne
pouvaient pas avoir d'enfant l'a
convaincu de porter un enfant conçu par
insémination artificielle est
génétiquement d'après les spécialistes
consultés
l'enfant sera exactement le même que
celui corps et portait la jeune femme
stérile puisque encore une fois les deux
soeurs sont de vraies jumelles un cas
humain exceptionnel paul lefebvre mais
aussi un cas juridique permis il ya
l'aspect juridique d'abord et à première
vue c'est facile première étape le père
naturel vous l'avez dit l'inséminateur
va reconnu l'enfant avant la naissance
la loi le permet l'enfant donc le statut
d'enfant naturelle reconnu par son père
deuxième étape à l'accouchement la mère
naturelle abandonne ses droits ne
reconnaît pas l'enfant dont l'ensemble
de la tutelle passe au père troisième
étape la femme du père naturel reconnaît
l'enfant naturel de son mari cela c'est
le schéma possible en utilisant quelques
astuces du texte oui mais en réalité il
ya un véritable vide juridique
bah oui parce qu'un tel cas ne s'est
jamais présentée en france du moins
officiellement
et là hop il apparaît tout de même de
l'observation d'abord il s'agit aux yeux
de la loi d'une véritable
substitution enfants d'une sorte de
substitution de l'adoption déguisé je
veux dire une session d'enfants de la
mère génétique à la mère naturelle une
appréciation des faits ouvertement avoué
peut t'amener d'ailleurs le procure de
la république à intervenir dans cette
affaire ensuite à 4 ce genre n'est
jamais isolé bien entendu d'autres
personnes risquent d'avoir l'âme à
l'idée puis de changer d'avis des
membres de la famille peuvent d'ailleurs
attaqué la reconnaissance de paternité
bref tout cela peut déboucher soit sur
une vague des tables industrie de l'
enfant adoptable
on a vu ça aux états unis ont pas encore
soit sur une sorte de conflit
une série de conflits dans les enfants
finalement ferait les frais alors le cas
de ces deux jeunes femmes va donc devoir
bûcher le l'islate heures qui déjà
embarrassé par tous les problèmes
soulevés par les enfants in vitro
amandine d'un souffle et le législateur
va devoir donc imaginer rapidement la
régulation la régularisation plutôt
légal de ce problème mais il ya aussi
bien sûr un aspect humain qui ne faut
pas oublier oui alors là c'est c'est un
autre aspect simplement beaucoup plus
important c'est de femmes qui sont des
jumelles sont liés par une affection
profonde d'une certaine manière c'est un
don d'une humanité extraordinaire que
l'une des soeurs fait à l'autre pour
préserver son équilibre naturel pour
préserver son couple pour préserver sa
vie c'est aussi important que le droit
et il vaut mieux en tout cas que ce se
soit fait tout à fait ouvertement la
faire des fausses factures découverte à
paris après marseille et nice sur les
six personnes interpellées hier quatre
dirigeants de sociétés ont été inculpés
et écroués aujourd'hui l'un d'eux aurait
des relations d'affaires avec plusieurs
municipalités communistes aux états unis
à new york les policiers sont convaincus
qu'ils tiennent en main la preuve
tangible des liens entre la mafia et le
trafic de drogue un réseau important
vient d'être démantelé à la cances nous
raconte l'histoire une histoire aussi
importante que celle de la french
connection il y a quelques années dans
ces sacs de plastique
dix kilos d'héroïne pure valeur à la
revente dans les rues de new york 20
millions de dollars 15 milliards de
centimes
l'une des plus grosses prises réalisées
ces dernières années par les agents du
narcotiques bureau la fère s'est joué
dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi peu
avant minuit ici au coin de la 55e ou de
la 1re avenue
un quartier résidentiel assez chic de
new york une cadillac remonte l'avenue
dans cette cadillac de personnes dans
son coffre
les sacs contenant les roms
les acheteurs sont au rendez vous mais
ces acheteurs sont en réalité des agents
du narcotiques bureau qui depuis des
mois ont infiltré le monde de la drogue
en se faisant passer pour des
trafiquants
les arrestations vont se poursuivre dans
la nuit dans différents quartiers de new
york et jeudi ce sont au total 13
personnes ont été inculpées toutes sont
connus pour appartenir à deux des
principales familles de la mafia de ceux
qu'on appelle ici le crime organisé dans
ce jean scène directeur du bureau des
narcotiques pour la région de new york
est fort satisfait de l'opération
nous sommes très satisfaits on pouvait
que ces résultats savent aussi qu'une
enquête qui a duré 16 mois
et c'est quand même rare quand vous
prenez des poissons de ce calibre de
cette envergure en train de remettre 20
kilos d'héroïne
mais un agent infiltré vous n'avez qu'à
bruit mais utiliser des agents infiltrés
peut quand même être dangereux d'une
part dangereux pour la sécurité des
agents et puis il faut bien le dire vous
pouvez les exposer à des tentations et
dangereux du travail s'ils le trouvent
trop dangereux il faut autre chose qui
concerne les tentations et bien jouer
non je ne pense pas qu'il ait plus de
plantation dans la drogue pour les
policiers qui s'occupe de contrôler le
jeu la prostitution tout ce qui implique
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent je dirai et
je pense que nos agents sont honnêtes on
aime à se dire nous
et puis vu les sommes énormes d'argent
que nous manions énormes sommes d'argent
je dirais que nous avons eu très peu
pour le dire pas du tout problème
pier luigi payet est mort sans avoir
parlé paliès ce terroriste italien
d'extrême droite soupçonné d'avoir
participé à l'attentât de bologne
il avait été enlevé de façon
spectaculaire
il ya un mois en bolivie par la police
et les services italiens grièvement
blessé lors de sa capture
il vient de mourir dans un hôpital de
rome l'un des plus beaux sites du monde
vient de disparaître au profit du plus
grand barrage jamais entrepris à la
frontière du brésil de l'argentine et du
paraguay
le barrage d itaipu a été officiellement
inauguré aujourd'hui six fois plus grand
que celui d'à souvent le nouveau barrage
alimentera en électricité la zone
industrielle de san paolo philippe
bénesse
on a beau être au siècle des machines il
aura tout de même fallu la présence de
quarante à cinquante mille ouvriers en
moyenne pendant sept ans pour construire
ce barak un barrage plus haut que la
tour montparnasse et cette fois plus
grand que celui d'assouan sur le nil un
barrage dont les 18 turbines fourniront
autant d'électricité que cinq centrales
nucléaires de quatre réacteurs chacune
avec cette construction tout est
démesuré on n'en finirait pas de citer
des chiffres de records mondiaux
mais toujours est il que son coût 100
milliards de francs environ ne
représente en fait qu'un an et demi
d'importation de pétrole pour le brésil
alors pour les économistes c'est une
très bonne opération mais pour bien
d'autres ce n'est pas aussi évident
d'abord le lac qui va se former va
recouvrir des milliers d'hectares de
très bonnes terres dans une région qui
n'en a pas trop ensuite cela que va
recouvrir une des merveilles du monde
les très belles chutes d'iguaçu situer
un peu avant le barrage dans quinze
jours on ne les verra plus enfin quelles
seront les conséquences à long terme sur
l'environnement
là il faudra attendre des dizaines
d'années pour savoir parlons sport
maintenant est d'abord football pour les
huitièmes de finale de la coupe de
l'uefa
bordeaux affrontera l'équipe romaine de
craiova match aller à bordeaux le 24
novembre match retour en roumanie le 8
décembre
après la très belle victoire des
bordelais surtout de giresse mercredi
dernier les bordelais au plus tôt fait
plus mal pour cette prochaine épreuve
même s'ils paraissent assez fragile à
l'extérieur en rugby un rendez vous plus
proche à toulouse dimanche aura lieu le
premier test-match entre l'équipe de
france et les argentins vous allez voir
la composition de l'équipe française a
voici aucun changement dans les lignes
arrières en revanche la charnière a
changé didier camberabero reste à
l'ouverture mais martinez remplace
berbizier le toulousain sera capitaine
car jean pierre rives ne jouera pas
reeves et joinel sont tous deux blessés
ils sont remplacés par erbani et bûcher
la première et la deuxième ligne sont
les mêmes que lors du match contre les
roumains c'est dimanche prochain qui
aura lieu à saint malo le départ de la
route du rhum
une épreuve devenue prestigieuse pour
les passionnés de la course de voile en
solitaire sur le long trajet de
saint-malo à pointe-à-pitre
c'est la deuxième fois seulement que
cette course a lieu mais tous les grands
marins sont là pour y participer sur des
engins souvent extraordinaire quelques
années 28 novembre 1978 au large de la
guadeloupe un petit trimaran jaune de 11
mètres boucle une traversée de plus de
3000 milles après 550 9h23 jours passés
en mer
michael burch gagne la 1ère édition de
la route du rhum avec 98 secondes
d'avancé sur michel malinowski une
arrivée qui contribuent à faire de cette
course en solitaire une épreuve de
légende ne course dure où les incidents
furent nombreux eugène riguidel s'en
souvient qui s'est échoué sur un récif
près de l'île de barbuda
mais aussi une course qui lui sa
tragédie la disparition en mer d'un
accola l'homme du 82 72 m l'homme au
pied sectionné puis recousu repartant
courageusement sur son vieux trimaran
manureva ce fut tout ça la route du rhum
qui repart demain à 13 heures de saint
malo toujours vers la guadeloupe avec
pour les voiliers de route possible
l'une au nord passant par les açores
l'autre plus sud venant frôlé madère et
les canaries
ils seront cinquante trois bateaux dont
40 multicoque et 13 monocoques en 1978
est l inverse les trimarans belle bus y
est encore aujourd'hui c'est un
déferlement
à tel point que tout pronostic sur les
marins ils sont tous là haut sur les
bateaux est impossible la route du rhum
c'est aussi et surtout une course en
solitaire avec toute la fascination les
mystères que cela comporte pour le
public
comment sur leurs engins dans le plus
grand sud aux jeunes riguidel à tavannes
7 m peuvent-ils manoeuvrer seul et
rythmé leurs moments de travail et de
semaine
et toi suivait en permanence le puits
afin de garder suffisamment de réserves
pour être prêt pour mears et dubaï avoir
à faire sans avoir une idée exacte du
programme donc on doit toujours aller au
maximum tout en gardant quand même une
réserve physique et morale pour non pas
une forme de pire mais une fente des
causes des forces supérieures qui peut
être demandé un moment donné on n'a pas
de programme de folie qui t'attend dans
l'erreur en cyclisme ou de réveil de les
avoir une cote d'antan le temps nous le
le schéma de la cote n'est pas écrit et
qui fait un peu la différence vin qui
fait revivre cette nécessité de pousser
faut regarder en même temps quelle est
la part de l'homme du bateau et de la
chance
il n'y a pas de victoire france n'a
jamais bu atteint gagne et ce après un
sondage de l'équipe magazine tabarly est
le grand favori de l'épreuve devant
pajot et quelque chose on est maintenant
rapidement le temps demain alain
gillot-pétré les brouillards s'en vont
mais la pluie arrive brouillard épilogue
pluies actuelles pour demain sur le
sud-est du pays c'est du beau temps sur
le l'est et le nord-est encore du
brouillard le matin et l'après midi sur
la moitié est comme vous le voyez
beaucoup de nuages sur la moitié ouest
beaucoup de nuages aussi mais là de la
pluie en plus c'est le même type de
temps pour dimanche sauf qu'il y aura du
vent ce qui ad'ailleurs facilitera le
départ de la course durant les
températures sont en hausse minima et
maxima minimum 8 degrés demain sur l'est
du pays maximum 19 degrés en corse
moyenne nationale 14 degrés ça va se
réchauffer d'ailleurs demain samedi 6
novembre de minutes de soleil en moins
levé 7h46 coucher 17h22 et la fin de
partie à 22h50 hervé claude main antenne
de midi daniel bilalian demain soir
patrick poivre d'arvor je vous
retrouverai dans une semaine
bonne soirée